please remember when your master
covering over both your nose and mouth
is required throughout our flight
my name is sebastian modek and i'm one
of many travel writers no longer
traveling
like many the thought of flying now
makes me nervous
but as a formerly frequent flyer i'm
also curious
many months into the kovit 19 pandemic i
wondered
what does the new normal of air travel
look like around the world
how are different airlines different
airports and different countries
responding to the pandemic
to find out i had to get on a flight and
stuck as i am in the united states for
the foreseeable future
i also needed to call on some others for
help
i can't believe how many shops are open
feeling pretty good about the flight
i decided to take a quick trip from new
york where i live
to chicago and back eva seau was set to
fly to istanbul on a reporting trip
and george downs was making the trip
home to london after a work visit to
toulouse
first i wanted to get an idea from
someone who knows what they're talking
about
of what i should and shouldn't do on a
plane so
i spoke to dr celine gander infectious
disease specialist and epidemiologist
at nyu and bellevue hospital
the risk on planes is really related to
the people who are closest to you on the
plane
the hvac systems on plane are quite
robust
and so the air exchanges you get on
planes are actually quite good
so it's the people sitting within a
couple rows of you that we really worry
about and masks
and potentially some sort of eye
covering face shields would be really
important for reducing that risk
then i was ready to fly by car by coach
by train george eva and i made our way
to our respective airports
and we were all struck by one thing i've
never seen it this empty
it does feel quiet in here this
station's usually
not this empty i had decided to fly two
different domestic airlines
to get an idea of what sets them apart
american airlines to chicago
delta airlines back to new york and even
when i bought the tickets i knew there
was going to be a difference
when i look at the seat maps on american
airlines
everything's up for grabs including the
middle seat
on delta however they've blocked out the
middle seat or at least it appears that
way
in george's case his entire route was
unusual a result of a drop in flight
frequency based on diminishing demand
i have to go to charles de gaulle in
paris
and then swap planes and go to london
from there
for eva things were mostly normal at
home the situation in turkey was more
uncertain
cherokees had over a thousand thousand
five hundred cases every day
uh whereas hong kong i think had seven
today
because of our different routes we had
different arrival regulations we had to
follow
in my case the arrival protocols in
chicago and new york
more closely resembled recommendations
than rules
it's kind of interesting that i'm seeing
the sign telling me
to quarantine as i'm leaving
because i did not see it as i as i
arrived in chicago
meanwhile george was ready for two weeks
of quarantine at home
when i traveled from england to france
that's a travel corridor
so i was able to arrive here and get
about my day without having to
quarantine
however the same unfortunately for me
doesn't work in the other direction
so when i get back i'm gonna have to
quarantine for two weeks
but even then when he arrived in london
he found that rules and processes had
seemed to relax a bit when i walked
through nobody took my temperature
eva meanwhile got tested before leaving
with a self-testing kit she acquired
from her doctor upon arriving in turkey
she would have to present a health
declaration form but there was no
quarantine requirement
she would have to quarantine at home
though when she returned to hong kong
perhaps the biggest change in flying
everywhere around the world regardless
of airline or destination
is the requirement to wear a mask it was
a mixed bag though when it came to
compliance
mask standards are slipping everyone's
wearing masks of course people just
coughing without their masks on and
things like that so i'm a little
nervous and in george's case there were
rules he had to follow about the type of
mask he was to wear
i'm just boarding the plane now so there
were signs everywhere saying that i had
to have a disposable surgical mask
specifically for this flight that's
despite dr gander telling me that cloth
surgical or kn 95 would all do the trick
any of those
that you showed us would be fine eva
brought back up
because of the length of her 12-hour
flight i've been told i should just wear
it for a maximum
of six hours so i actually have another
one have to switch in the middle
before flying i had heard from some
people that the boarding process had
changed
from the cryptic zone system to a far
more logical and far more coded safe
back-to-front process it turns out that
was only the case with some airlines
eva who was flying turkish airlines had
that experience
looks like they're boarding from the
back to the front
and i only had that experience on my way
back when flying delta
on american airlines by contrast not
only were middle seats not blocked out
and the plane packed
but the boarding process was business as
usual
delta said it will be blocking off
middle seats at least through january 6
2021.
american confirmed it is not blocking
middle seats nor has it changed its
boarding process
the airline did say it informs customers
when a flight is full
and allows them to change to a more open
flight without fees
george's flights were full and not only
were middle seats not blocked off
but he found himself in one in my case
it was one of many parts of the process
i found surprising
mainly how different the experience was
between delta and american
two of the united states big three
airlines as a passenger i've always
thought there has been very little light
between the two
through their responses to the pandemic
that has changed
on my first flight to chicago
besides the face masks not a lot had
changed
this flight back to new york was a whole
other story
uh there was constant reminders that
this was not normal
the middle seats were blocked nobody was
sitting next to anyone else
amenities were altered across the board
no matter what plane we were on
on american i received nothing but a
single wet wipe
flight attendants only appeared to
collect garbage
on delta i got the wipe plus a ziploc
bag of snacks and water
eva got a full boxed cold meal her
hygiene kit was quite a bit more
impressive than the single wipes both
george and i were treated to
when i arrived back in new york at a
kiosk near baggage claim i was asked to
fill out
paperwork with my personal information
in it i agreed to quarantine for 14 days
a week after my flight i hadn't been
contacted by anyone to check that i was
so what is flying like in 2020 the short
answer
is it depends safeguards vary widely
from country to country and even within
one country
most people are still choosing to
postpone their trips in the week we
traveled in mid-october for example
the number of scheduled flights was down
47 compared to last year
in the united states during that week
the number of travelers going through
tsa checkpoints surpassed 1 million for
the first time since march
but that's still less than half as many
as last year
no transit authority airport or airline
has figured out a standard
one-size-fits-all model to being 100
safe in these unprecedented times
passenger numbers reflect the
uncertainty
many feel around air travel right now